and the championship flag is being
raised at the center field plaza out in
left center field to the right of the
american flag which stands the tallest
of the three and of course to the left
the dc flag
symbolism there from all players unified
in their
continued
exhibition for their
social justice reforms they'd like to
see and an empty stadium and no
acknowledgement from the fans and no
acknowledgement to the fans from those
there so what you'll see
from baseball 2020 we get a real good
feel for tonight and now one of the more
well-known washington national fans dr
anthony fauci to throw out the first
pitch
[Applause]
dr anthony fauci
[Music]
and on the mound for the defending world
series champs the three-time cy young
award winner max scherzer has all four
pitchers maddie he's got a fastball
cutter slider changeup occasional get me
over curveball as hicks lines the ball
to second base
new net starlin castro is there for the
first out of 2020. all in a strike to
count aaron judge
and that one's ripped into left field
the first base hit of 2020. so judge at
second with two men out and here is
giancarlo judge off second with two out
and it'll be a 1-1 to stand and the
pitch is swung on and hit high in the
ear to left center that ball is high it
is far it is gone a way back in the left
center field seats a stantonian home run
giancarlo
no si stoparlo it's a two-run dinger and
the yankees immediately take a
two-nothing lead full count three balls
and two strikes to brett gardner already
two-nothing yankees in d.c tonight and
max scherzer has his first strikeout of
the year 20-5 overall last year there
were 17 pitchers who won at least 15
games last season now the batter is out
of eaton now the pitch swing by eaton
and a drive to deep right field judge
going back way back looking up going
going gone goodbye
adam eaton cuts the yankees lead in half
an outstanding at bat and a long home
run over the big 14 foot eight inch wall
in right center field so it'll be a one
two to kendrick and garrett cole deals
slider strike three on the outside
corner to wrap up the first inning one
run one hit now to the top of the second
here gary sanchez
and a wave to miss by sanchez second
strikeout for scherzer tonight
that's three straight strikeouts for max
scherzer now with two down here is
archella here's the wine of the pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a slider and scherzer strikes out the
side
here in the second inning that's four
strikeouts in a row for scherzer is
aaron hicks weighed with good speed at
first and the pitch is swung on and
missed and that folks is what makes max
scherzer so nasty just a small part of
it here's aaron judge with one on and
one out
cut on and line the left field as a base
hit down the line cut off in the corner
by stevenson as wade rounds third coming
home the throw is cut off it's a double
for judge a ribby double and the yankees
take a 3-1 lead ball in two strikes to
the 2017 national league mvp
and he struck him out
two more punch outs in the inning yet
the yankees scratch across a run
left-handed batter waiting the max's o2
outside corner strike three called ring
him up with a change up gardner didn't
like the call six punch outs for max
scherzer so far tonight
make it seven as he gets sanchez to
swing and miss
and the yankees have the bases loaded
and here is giancarlo
and scherzer's pitch is swung on and
lined
down the right field on it is a base hit
one run scores so stanton comes through
again and the yankees take a 4-1 lead
four earned runs tonight and counting
swing and a miss struck him out with a
slider cutter running in on him and that
retires the side the tenth strikeout for
max scherzer here is left-hand hitting
andrew stevenson all right here's the
one two
half swing did he go he did
it was a slider in the dirt
but he did go
and there
are two way that strikeout number four
for garrett cole and that will bring up
the ninth hitter right hand hitting
victor robles
on the corner to ring him up strikeout
number five for garrett cole and i just
saw some lightning you can see the rain
coming down
here is wade and he takes a fastball
outside in the count one on o
and they're going to call time so rain
comes down and
puts the game on hold yankees leading
4-1 runners at the corners with one out
they wanted very much to try to get the
game in first game of the year espn
national tv and they waited two hours
pouring
and still pouring
anyway
that is your your ball game yankees win
it by the score of four to one